welcome to another dr sadler's honest
review this is a video series in which i
do exactly that i provide
honest unvarnished objective reviews
of books of a wide range of natures
mostly centered
in practical philosophy very broadly
speaking so that extends over to
self-help
and to leadership and into some other
dimensions as well the book that i'm
reviewing today
is solidly within the realm of practical
philosophy because
it's adapting a philosophy that was
already practically oriented
in the ancient period to modern times
and that book
is tending the epicurean garden by
hiram crespo and i do want to say a
little bit
more than i usually do before jumping
into the review
so this is a book that was sent to me by
the author
uh from the publisher oh about
you know three or four years ago when i
first wanted to review it
it came out in 2014 so it's a little bit
older than some of the books
that i've been reviewing and i have been
behind on on doing some of these reviews
and this is one that i
kept wanting to get to but never managed
to
in in all of these months so i'm really
happy
to be able to finally give this book
the review that it deserves and i will
say right from the start
i do recommend this book i think it's
actually quite good
and you'll hear me tell you why in just
a few minutes
so i'm really you know i want to say
thanks to to hear him
for sending this to me so long ago and
finally the review is coming out
i always like to begin these reviews by
talking about the three big
s's style structure and a summary of
what the the work is about so that you
have an
idea right off the bat and let's start
with the summary so
this is a work within a
genre taking ancient philosophy adapting
it more or less successfully
to modern times i would say that this is
very successful in that and so
it fits into a whole class of recent
books from the last you know 10 or 15
years
where people are taking an ancient
philosophy stoicism is very popular with
this there's a few
other books out on epicureanism and then
there's a few on on other things as well
and they're they're trying to find
ways to relate it to the
issues the challenges the problems of
modern life and they're saying that that
this will help you out and so
hirom is doing that for epicureanism
although he's bringing in a lot of other
things as well
i would say that if i had to summarize
that this is a really
solid examination application
and reinterpretation of classical
epicurean doctrines and practices
rethought out for a modern reader
and for modern life so that that's
probably enough
of a summary let's talk about the
structure of the work
it's divided into 15 chapters
all of which are fairly short they're
more or less
you know equal in length and importance
and
it proceeds in a rational way it starts
out with you know making the case for
why we need philosophy today um starts
telling us about epicurus
a little bit of history of him the uh
then he starts going into some of the
key ideas like the the four
remedies um how epicureanism is a form
of
therapy or a way of healing and then it
gets into all these
other you could say sub topics that are
connected with that
and throughout you know hear him is
bringing in
quotes and ideas from the
epicurean uh text that we we have
available
each chapter actually concludes with a
few things
um it's kind of i i'm not gonna you know
say that this is
bad or anything like that but he he uses
the word
verbiage which i actually kind of like
uh for talking about
key terms right it's kind of common in
textbooks
that you'll have like what are the key
ideas so he he calls it new verbiage
in in you know one chapter it's ataraxia
good
gratitude journal and hedonic calculus
and then he'll
also typically have sources that he's
drawing on for each chapter
um the the sources by the way we're
going to talk about this later on pretty
good selection here
and then he'll also have what he calls
tasks and some of these are tied
in with journaling some of them are
other things that you can try to do
so these tasks are really practices that
are
guided by the epicurean doctrine and
each chapter
has some of these things not not every
chapter has all of them
some chapters do have you know both
verbiage tasks and
sources the style very readable
um hiram is is a good writer
and he's very competent he uh
he's done a lot of good research that
that's clearly
the case in here and as he points out
this book is structured to be what he
calls an interactive experience and
i think sometimes when it comes to this
genre of literature
the authors don't quite pull it off i
would say he actually does
this this is quite good um even to the
point where
if you disagree with it you're engaged
in a kind of dialogue
with hiram and with the sources that
he's he's talking about
he also brings in a character hermarcus
to sort of personalize stuff as sort of
an example of
of what you you know might see an
epicurean in the present day
doing so that tells you probably enough
about style structure and
summary now we should talk about some of
the really key ideas
so this is a book that is you could say
chock
full of ideas as a matter of fact i
don't think you can go
more than a page without running into
some key
epicurean idea or an idea drawn from
another
wisdom tradition and the chapters give
you some of the
key ideas you know for example there's a
chapter on autarky
which means independence what is what
does genuine independence look like
back in ancient times what does it look
like in our own times in terms of like
work
diet all these sorts of issues there's
another great chapter in here on the
treasure of friendship
the epicureans thought following
epicurus that friendship was one of the
things that
made our lives valuable so there's an
entire chapter devoted to that
there are some interesting discussions
about um
you know freedom and determinism there
is a chapter on epicurean
therapy philosophy as a way of life as a
way of
improving our lives there's a great
chapter there on
you know epicurus sort of laying out
what what the history
uh that we can piece together which
isn't an awful lot but but he does so in
a competent way
and you know there's a lot of other
ideas
in here i would say that that one of the
key ideas that is
introduced in the first chapter and then
runs throughout the work
quite successfully is that epicureanism
was always a practical tradition
it wasn't engaging in theory for
its own sake although the epicureans did
think that theoretical activity
for those who like that sort of thing
was uh very pleasurable and it was a
great way to
spend your time
so you know epicureanism is a practical
and wisdom
tradition another key thing that comes
up at the start and then runs throughout
and i think it's
demonstrated as a key idea and as a
practice
is the the need for epicureanism to
evolve and reinterpret itself
that is through practitioners of
epicureanism
so this is a very important idea you
know it's not supposed to be
leaving epicureanism behind in it being
sort of a blind dogmatic cult which by
the way
they were often accused of uh
you know in in antiquity of just saying
well the master said so so we we have to
act this way
it provides a nice as i mentioned
history of epicurus and his movement
including the development of the what we
can call the modern
school now you know it brings up thomas
jefferson
it could have brought in pierre gescendy
a bit more but you know
one can always you know ask more of an
author than they
they deliver but when we're talking
about the modern thing
we're really talking about the society
of epicurus
and this vision that hirom expresses in
here for developing
a new set of gardens a new set of
intentional
communities that would be you know
similar on the epicurean side to
what stoicism modern stoicism has done
in having local stoas or local stoic
fellowships and so i think that that's
another key one
um something else that's so
basic but i i really do need to say it
for the for
for people who don't know about this
about the epicureans
so the epicurean philosophy was hedonic
or hedonistic it focused on pleasure and
pain
and they said that pleasure and pain
were the end or the goal
of of human life avoiding pain
having as much pleasure as possible they
were the things that we use to measure
what we're doing to guide choices
and and you know choosing against things
and
that's really well captured in here
there's a lot of analyses
drawing on classic epicurean ideas and
then bringing in things
from modern psychology for example
even some marketing things to help us
better understand
and analyze what is genuinely
pleasurable for us and why
and what seems to be pleasurable but
gets us into trouble and causes us
pains and disruptions and what sort of
things do we
have troubles and fears about that we
don't need to
so i think that's that's particularly
good you're going to get a
a really decent discussion
of how the epicureans viewed these
things
here another thing that i think is
really quite good in here
is there's some discussions about the
need for mindfulness
and paying attention you know sort of a
discipline
of focusing uh in in one's life so
this is discussed uh at a couple
different points
in in this um
yeah looking at hedonic adaptation and
what's going on with ourselves
how we can keep our minds from wandering
you know different aesthetic practices
that can help with that
there's also a discussion of mindfulness
a little bit later on
in the work uh what page here we go 86
where um it's talking again about
similarities between what epicureans
might have been doing and um
zen practice right so you know this is a
great example of how
what was just implicit in epicurean
theoria or contemplation
would be developed differently in
it by bringing in techniques and ideas
from other traditions
the other thing that i think is
particularly
important in talking about key ideas is
that
epicureanism as a practical philosophy
has to be applied to all the aspects of
one's life that's what what it means to
have a philosophy of life it's not just
philosophy of this part of your life but
philosophy of the totality of your life
and
i would say that you know if we only had
epicurus as texts we don't really have
quite enough to go on
this is a book that attempts to remedy
that that problem
looking at how we run our finances for
example and you know whether it's good
to take on credit card debt or not
very practical questions like that so
those are some of the key ideas from
this book
so what did i find good about this
relatively short book it's it's only 185
pages total i actually like this book
quite a bit
i'm not an epicurean you know but i do
think that there's a lot to be
said about the epicurean ideas and
approaches to things and i would say
that
hiram has done a really excellent job
and a really well-structured job in
putting
this work together for the contemporary
reader it's always challenging to
reinterpret movements in philosophy
or thinkers that we don't have an awful
lot of source texts
on especially when some of the material
that we have
is from those who were opposed to their
doctrines those who are
polemicizing against them and that's the
case for epicurus
and so i would say that you know hirum
really gets a lot of
thoughtful mileage out of what we do
have of the
epicureans now obviously that doesn't
just mean epicurus but also some
inscriptions that we have
he references um you know lucretius
as well i mentioned thomas jefferson and
then we have
philodemus who we've got you know
scrolls from
some of which have been damaged uh so
they're incomplete and some of which
were finding over time
and this book at the time that it was
written incorporated
the best of that that research so i
think that's a real high point of the
book i think he did an excellent job
with that
another thing i really love about this
book is that it has
so many useful practices
some of which are drawn from directly
from the epicureans the classic
epicureans
some of which are taking epicurean ideas
and saying well how can we
turn this into a practice how can we
operationalize this you might say
and business speak and then some of
which are actually drawn from
other wisdom traditions saying you know
they've got something good over there
like for example buddhist uh mediterrane
loving-kindness meditation could that be
used
in an epicurean way a hiram thinks that
it can and
he does so in the work and so i think
that that's
really awesome to offer people a lot of
practices that they can try out
experiment with experience what the
results are
and then come back and reflect on it
that's very important in a work
like this another thing that i've
already mentioned several times but i
think is a really high point of the work
although i have to qualify this when i
get to the one i found problematic
there is a lot of engagement with other
traditions
of philosophy and even you know
some religious traditions like like
hinduism and and buddhism
and so i think that you know being
willing to learn
from whoever has something useful and
then incorporate it that's the sign of a
living tradition that's something that
aleister mcintyre has written quite
about you know
quite a lot about if you want your
tradition to stay alive you don't just
stick with the stuff that you've got you
poach everybody else's stuff
and you make it your own and so you know
that that's been done quite
well here um i think that there's a
really good
reinterpretation of this idea of
pleasure as an end or goal and i'm going
to read a little bit uh from the text
here he says
i don't necessarily treat pleasure as a
goal in the way that
philosophers speak of the telos the aim
or ultimate goal in life
and why because he brings up a scholar
from
harvard university matt killingworth it
indicates that we're
happiest when we're not seeking
happiness but wrapped in the moment
happiness requires focus and is a mode
of being not a
mode of seeking and so you know he he
talks about what are the implications
for this
the philosophically hedonist theory that
epicurus proposed
is um calls for a preliminary process of
introspection
discerning between unnecessary and
unnecessary desires and so
he's bringing in some ideas but he's
reworking
the idea of happiness or you know
eudaimonia
as as the end here in a way that i think
is very
thoughtful there's also a really nice
although short discussion of what the
epicureans
had to say about anger
this is something that a lot of people
struggle with today probably just as
much as
in ancient time and so this gets a you
know
fairly sustained treatment we're getting
[Music]
at least yeah five pages devoted to it
and so that that's quite good so there's
a lot of things that i think are
excellent
in this work
no work is usually perfect and there are
a few things that i do find problematic
about this work
one is just a few mistakes here and
there
which might have been the result of
trying to
simplify things for the reader you know
for example
uh calling the carvaka materialist
school
in in ancient india a hindu school it
was not an orthodox hindu school it's
you know definitely outside of that so
that's you know that's a mistake
i i don't know whether i imagine
actually
hiram knows that but it got in there
that's not that big of a deal something
that i find a bit more
problematic and and i want to say
something here that doesn't just apply
to this book
but generally applies to anything
about epicureanism that is advocating
epicureanism
and often even more broadly the hedonist
tradition
there's some bad history in there
there's some some bad history of ideas
and some bad history of religion and
you know it's it's interesting because
it's
it's distracting it doesn't need to be
in there
an epicurean can do just fine without
bashing platonism
without bashing christianity without
getting these things wrong
right um so i and this is a failure in a
lot of this literature
so you know hear him crespo falls into
that
trap as as do so many others i'll just
give you a few examples
of this you know he talks about
platonism
uh in a way that's clearly incorrect and
i i think is unfair uh he says
for example we must keep in mind that to
the platonus reason was a separate
entity a deity with a concrete identity
we hold this to be a false view there's
absolutely no reason to believe our
reasoning faculty is divine or exists in
a supernatural or eternal realm
well the plaintiffs didn't actually buy
into that
and that's sort of a misconstrual of of
platonism
in in general and you wonder well what's
what's the beef there what what are they
getting
out of that and you know it's they'd be
better off leaving that sort of stuff
behind
there's a particularly tip you know
typical bad history passage
a little bit later in the work you know
which starts with the burning of the
library of alexandria uh you know the
philosophical schools being closed and
for over a thousand years the people
succumbed to the superstition
ignorance misery and feudal slavery of
the dark ages from which we have still
not made a full recovery so i mean
that's
that's just garbage history right you
know that could be in gibbon or
whatever whatever i mean real historians
know that the dark ages did happen but
it was very
very short and christianity and you know
particularly christian monks were the
ones preserving the knowledge
expanding it getting us out of the dark
ages
so you know that sort of stuff i don't
need to belabor the point
it's just kind of silly detraction
that doesn't need to be there because
the rest of the work is really quite
good
so those are really the only things that
i found particularly
problematic about the work
so my last thoughts are usually very
brief but i'm actually going to include
a little bit from the text in this case
something that i think is actually quite
important and why i think
this book even if you don't want to like
be an epicurean
why i think if you're interested in
intentional communities and philosophy
as a way of life i think you should get
this book
so uh hiram crespo says as autonomous
value creating communities
the epicurean gardens may one day become
spaces where people
perform rites of passage according to
their authentic needs
and informed choices what he's talking
about there
is doing something like i
said people have done in other movements
and taking epicureanism and making it
part
of an intentional community life and i
think that is really
quite interesting a little bit later
in the work he says that spaces of
refuge
we create must be subcultures of
philosophy sustainable economics and
non-consumerism
and because of that the very creation of
those spaces inherently constitutes a
political
and subversive act in our consumerist
society so he has a real
program here and i think the you know uh
society of the friends of epicurus is
part of that
the entire 13th chapter is about
what he calls the matter of cultural
continuity and
he's talking about how to draw things
from other traditions
the teaching mission wisdom is of value
he talks about the society of the
friends of
epicurious and about the what he calls
the 20th
urs the people of epicurus those who
celebrate the birthday of epicurus so
this is this is in some respect
not just a self-help book but kind of a
manifesto for
a movement that is existing today and is
well worth
checking out if you're interested in
intentional life so i
you know without any qualification
recommend this
book uh it's it's a very you know
quick read but quite rich and well worth
having on your bookshelf
you